you probably hate him he's frustrated
you he's gotten play the game he's
merged you a thousand times its Bastion
here on overwatch hero guides Donnie
Dwyer joined by Mary Kish Mary
everyone loves a bastion right yeah
everyone who is a bastion loves Bastion
that's a good point and let's get this
out of the way hard counters against
Bastion use Widowmaker use Farah high
damage from a distance plywood on top of
Bastion that's right once he's in his
sentry mode he's really weak from behind
so actually even like a tracer or anyone
who can get behind him I just double
damage on his head beautiful but we're
not talking to the countering Bastion
we're talking about being Bastion let's
talk over first bet his first
configuration his recon configuration
this is basically him with a submachine
gun this thing any good Mary it's more
mid in close range and he actually can
take a lot of damage when he's doing
this you kind of want to use it more for
mobility to get to the best place for
your sentry I wouldn't really use that
for anything else yes sentry
configuration so you basically hit that
shift button and he is able to turn into
a big ol turret he can throw around 360
degrees he can fire bullets at a massive
pace and what is the sort of key to
using this effectively very well he does
great long range in that and he can
easily take down people and then shoot
past them so you want to always get
people in groups get people going down
an alley get people where they're all
going the same way and you just mow Mall
down you want to be in a corner or
against a wall because again your back
is really easy to be damaged but you
always want to position yourself
somewhere where you get a nice oversee
of the area that way you can just kind
of pick off people especially people
with low HP you're you're really good
against mercy right so you want to get
yourself in a corner we have a really
nice range the field or up high so you
can look down on everyone and shoot them
from above he's able to repair himself
as well which is just as well because
you going to be attracting a lot of
attention when should you use so from
there you actually want to use it
anytime you're not taking fire and you
need help so you know just get into the
habit of always using it but you
actually can't use it if you're taking
fire so before you use it
put yourself in like a corner you don't
think you're going to get shot not only
can you not heal when you're taking fire
but there's a cool-down of like a couple
seconds so your rush you're just wasting
time okay it sounds a lot like actually
playing someone like Widowmaker where
you're taking shot you're shooting and
shooting and then
you're like oh no they know where I am
now and I'm just gonna maybe move
position and heal myself while I'm doing
it
Widowmaker has to like go find a medevac
but Bastian can sort of do himself he
can also heal while he's jumping too so
go ahead and jump he'll jump and heal
your way to somebody can you also change
configurations while jumping you can you
can change configurations and it's a
faster way to reload so if you're out of
bullets and you're taking fire go ahead
and change your configuration you start
with a fresh reload and it's quicker
than reloading in your sentry confirm
rise perfect if you get caught by a
tracer or something let's talk a little
bit a bit as alt did to do everyone goes
running he turns into a mobile century
and can blow people asunder when should
you use this and who should you be
targeting so your shells do long range
and they do blast damage so you actually
just want to hurl shells at basically
anyone's direction
you also get increased armor so you
don't have to be too afraid you can kind
of move forward and do damage but it
works really well in tandem with other
people who can give you additional armor
or increase your damage like a mercy
yeah I feel like it's really good close
range with against everyone except maybe
a tank like a Reinhardt can still hit
you pretty hard with his hammer if
you're up close yeah but yeah the best
thing about it is I feel like when that
Sam goes off everyone just goes running
that's right and it's because of the
blast damage so if you can get people
grouped together using like mace ice
wall or as Aria is Gravitron then you're
basically just curling shells and doing
massive damage at a huge group of people
and so let's talk we already talked
about the sort of hard calendars for
this you know you want to stay away from
sniper lanes I feel like the minute you
are touched by one sniper shot you need
to get out of your turqu configuration
and find someone else to be a Farah as
well if you get hit by a rocket get out
of there but who else is there
you know in terms of flanking or stuff
I'm guessing like Genji and tracer right
Genji is really bad because he can
deflect the bullets at you and it can
actually kill you really quickly you're
a big target for those as well that's
right it's almost too late by the time
you shot at him they're coming back at
you Bastion used to have a shield in one
of the earlier betas okay he I know
right completely and he used to be able
to protect a Torbjorn turret as well
with the size of his shield
so although that's gone you can still
double up with a Reinhardt sitting on
top of the payload so you know you got a
free shield right there yeah he's a
powerful guy to use with other
characters to just increase his damage
enjoy those play the games that van is
one
our last overwatch hero guides here on
gang Spock on a youtube channel make
sure to check out our playlist 3 load
more tips for overwatch